madame la contrôleur générale mes chers
collègues nous recevons aujourd'hui
madame Dominique chimono Contrôleur
général des lieux de privation de
liberté pour nous présenter son rapport
annuel d'activité publié en mai dernier
je précise que vous êtes accompagné de
Monsieur André ferang secrétaire général
du contrôleur général d' privation
liberté que nous sommes également
heureux d'accueillir avant vous donner
la parole madame la contrôleur générale
pour nous présenter les grandes lignes
de votre rapport je tiens rappeler que
la commission des lois demeure très
attentive à la préservation de la
dignité des personnes privées de liberté
tout comme parti culièrement aux
conditions de détention dans
l'établissement pénitentiaire comme
l'ont montré les les débats très riches
sur cette question lors de l'examen du
projet d'orientation et programmation
pour le ministère pour de la justice
pardon par ailleurs le bureau a souhaité
que la Commission prenne toute sa part
dans ce débat sur le thème de la
régulation carcérale en confiant à
Madame Abad et Madame fausillon une
mission d'information sur les
alternatives à la détention et
l'éventuelle création d'un mécanisme de
régulation carcérale et les conclusions
de ce rapport ont été présenté le 19
juillet dernier je rappelle enfin que le
champ d'intervention de votre autorité
ne se limite pas au prison puisquil
inclu aussi les lieux de privation
liberté comme les établissements
psychiatriques les centres de rétention
administrativ les zones d'attente les
centres éducatifs fermés les locaux et
conditions de garde à vue et donc je
vais vous donner la parole pour la
présentation du rapport j'aurai quelques
questions probablement ensuite et les
questions de mes collègues vous seront
ensuite posées pour une durée maximale
chacune de 2 minutes vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président et
merci de me recevoir ici c'est toujours
impressionnant
euh voilà de parler devant la
représentation nationale alors notre
rapport je vais vous le présenter
évidemment il y a eu des avancées depuis
enfin des choses qui se sont passées
depuis depuis que notre rapport est
sorti et je vais commencer
par ce que dans l'avant propos que j'ai
écrit j'appelle l'abandon par l'État à
la fois des des gens qui sont enfermés
et de ceux qui sont chargés de les
garder ou de les soigner ou de les
éduquer pourquoi parce que en prison par
exemple euh les surveillants nous
confient leur détresse les les
directeurs nous confient leur
euh pas leur panique mais c'est pas loin
ils nous disent que comme vous le savez
peut-être la prison qui est devenue un
grand hôpital psychiatrique
ou un asile d'ENT temp si on veut il y a
plus de 30 % de gens atteints de graves
troubles psychiques les directeurs nous
disent qu'il redoute à chaque
instant un incident très grave que il
s'étonne qu'il y en ait pas déjà eu de
très grave et il y en a d'ailleurs tous
les jours je rappelle qu'il y a 250
morts en prison chaque année dont 120
suicides 7p fois plus qu'à l'extérieur
que en prison il y a 15 % d'î ltré qui
ressortent î ltrée parce que dans les
maisons d'arrêt il y a tant de monde que
ils n'ont pas
accès tout est tous les accès
à la culture à l'enseignement au travail
au sport tout est
contraint par la surpopulation je
rappelle que il est prévu normalement un
surveillant pour 50 détenus mais dans
les coursiv c'est 1 pour 120 un
surveillant pour 120 détenus ce qui fait
que étant donné les les normes de
sécurité je vous conseille de vous
pencher là-dessus les avis rendus par
les sous commommission de sécurité dans
ces
endroits-là sont très étonnamment
favorables à la poursuite de
l'activité alors que nous ce que nous
voyons sont des fils dénudés pendant
au-dessus des bouilloirs des
installations électriques effroyables et
surtout les sous-commissions de sécurité
se prononcent au vu du nombre de places
théoriques d'une prison par exemple euh
et non en fonction du nombre de
résidents de la prison
qui est quand
même une façon
avouez-le très en très inquietttante je
trouve et nous on va se pencher beaucoup
là-dessus cette année sur les la
sécurité parce que de plus les médecins
qui travaillent en prison sont venus ont
analysé pour nous le fait que il y avait
tellement de monde les surveillants sont
tellement renvoyés à à leur impuissance
professionnelle parce que vous imaginez
ce que c'est de se lever le matin puis
de se coucher le soir en disant j'ai mal
fait mon travail euh je suis incapable
de remplir ma tâche et ben ça crée ils
disent que il y a de forts risques de
décompensation psychique côté détenu et
côté surveillant
euh voilà alors pour les prisons bien
sûr nous avons soutenu avec euh avec euh
enthousiasme je dirais le la opposition
de Caroline Abad et Elsa
fossillon
qui à le courage
d'aller d'aller pardon d'aller bon enfin
d'aller au fond des choses et d'aller de
proposer quelque chose de
viable en
regard je trouve que le gouvernement s
vite assis si je peux me permettre cette
expression un peu triviale sur les états
généraux de la just
qui eux préconisaient une régulation
carcérale en tout cas une décélération
carcérale
euh et la restriction des entrées par le
biais des restrictions des
comparitiontions immédiates donc je vous
dirai un mot parce que elles se sont
subreptissement allongé elles se sont on
a créé plusieurs sortes de comparition
immédiate la comparition immédiate à
délais différé la comparitionition
immédiate comme avant les fux flag et
puis une autre forme qui est la
la
reconnaissance préalable de culpabilité
soit le PLA des
coupables avec mandat de dépôt
c'est-à-dire ça s'appelle le CRPC déferm
qui est pourvoyeuse d'énormément de
mandat de dépôt également d'ailleurs je
vous signale que les avocats de crétaill
sont en grève contre cette forme de de
déferement bon je voudrais vous
parler donc de l'urgence qu'il y a non
pas à adopter des attitudes incantatoire
face à la catastrophe des prisons et je
dis la catastrophe parce que on paye 110
€ par jour et par détenu comme ma écrit
très ironiquement indétenu ça fait
beaucoup pour fabriquer de la
récidive et c'est un problème qu'on doit
regarder de façon
pragmatique c'est pas c'est pas faire un
cadeau au détenu c'est c'est réfléchir
au sens de la peine au sens qu'on veut
donner à une punition qui ne peut pas
être un châtiment corporel comme il est
en ce moment dans des cellules ultra
bondées grouillantes de vermine avec
moins d'un m carré d'espace vital par
personne pour se mouvoir parce qu'il
faut réfléchir à l'après ces gens-là
dans les maisons d'arrêt ils ont
vocation à sortir ils vont sortir donc a
temps qu'ils sortent dans le meilleur
état qu'ils aient appris un métier je
vais vous prendre l'exemple de
l'Allemagne 7 % des détenus travaillent
en Allemagne contre 28 % ici et tous ont
accès à des AC
intellectuelle culturelle sportive et
cetera pourquoi parce que ça sert à à
boucher les trous de l'éducation qui n'a
pas été donné et et ça sert à faire que
la prison ne soit pas un temps mort
c'est quand même stupide de payer si
cher pour ressortir dans des états pires
que ce qu'on est entré c'est pas très
français ma phrase mais je crois que
vous avez compris le sens et je voudrais
pas passer là au centre éducatif fermé
et à l'enfance c'est un énorme problème
vous aurez à vous y pencher j'en suis
sûr sur l'aide sociale à l'enfance qui
n'est pas capable d'assumer sa tâche les
enfants
maltraités on parle d'enfants qui n'ont
pas eu de chance dès le départ
maltraités sont retirés à des familles
maltraitante pour être placé dans des
foyers de l'enfance
ou des familles d'accueil qui sont peu
ou très mal contrôlé et où ils sont
souvent maltraités également ensuite il
passent les foyers de l'enfant les
foyers PJJ il se retrouvent nous on les
retrouve dans les centres éducatifs
fermés la situation des centres
éducatifs fermés je vous recommande vous
aurez à vous y pencher parce que je
crois qu'il est prévu la construction de
dizaines de nouveaux centres éducatifs
fermés faites bien attention parce que
moi j'ai rencontré récemment les
directeurs de ces centres qui nous
disent qu'ils sont inondé le mot est est
pas joli mais bon dans en de plus dans
des états de plus en plus inquiétants
psychiatriquement
parlant des enfants qui souffr de troubl
cognitif énorme de de pathologie mental
énorme il nous disent soit-disant on
devrait avoir un éducateur fil rouge
tout au long depuis le début qui
s'occupe de l'enfant c'est il
l'appelleent l'étoile filante ils
apprennent une fois que l'enfant est
placé chez eux mais bien plus tard 3
mois plus tard que B ah il il avait un
traitement psychiatrique et des piqûes
retard mais comment vous voulez faire
cohabiter des enfants dans des états
pareils avec des enfants qui qui sont
certes délinquants mais qui vont
mentalement
bien alors je sais que je laisserai la
parole à André sur sur les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et la situation de la
psychiatrie mais je vous assure que
c'est très inquiétant les centres
éducatifs fermés pour le moment il
fonctionnent on le voit il fonctionneent
bien quand ils ont une équipe pérenne
solide ancienne euh et ça n'est pas le
cas ça n'est pas le cas c'est rare on en
rendontre des formidables des
sensationnels on a envie de dire mais
pourquoi les gosses peuvent pas y rester
plus longtemps c'est dommage et bien on
en rencontre d'autres où on se dit il
faut qu'il ferme c'est pas possible je
vous raconterai pas les mes aventures
qui nous sont arrivées dans ces centres
où je vous les raconte une autre fois
mais je vous assure que c'est édifiant
hein
quand on
tombe notamment sur une directrice
qu'est-ce que vous voulez je vous le dis
qui couche avec les gosses
bah on se dit que quelque chose ne va
pas dans le recrutement
ou dans la surveillance ou dans je ne
sais pas quoi enfin c'est quand même
plus qu'étonnant je dirais
euh et donc cette conjonction d'enfant
délinquant et de et de psychiatrie
défaillante euh qui rentre certes pas
dans votre champ mais qui
devrait et qui fait aussi que la prison
est un immense Asil
euh ça n'est ça n'est pas tenable quand
on vous dit je je vous expliquerai aussi
sur les centres de rétention on a été
amené à rendre des recommandations en
urgence sur la façon dont dont ils sont
gérés pourquoi parce que les étrangers
sont envoyés en zone de ce qu'on appelle
une zone de vie où les policiers chargés
de les garder ne rentrent pas parce
qu'ils ont de plus en plus peur des
retenus et que les retenus ont de plus
en plus peur deux
euh simplement dans ces zones de vie
c'est la loi du plus fort c'est le Kaïda
euh les chambres ne ferment pas donc les
gars ils mettent des des des serviettes
de toilettes ou des draps qui font tenir
avec du dentifrice séché pour tenir euh
pour prévenir les intrusions dans leur
chambrre tellement ils ont peur euh je
dire dirait que le travail des policiers
n'est pas la garde c'est un travail de
surveillant les policiers ne sont pas
formés à la garde et et ils sont eux
aussi laissés à l'abandon dans des
endroits où on on a changé la politique
puisque on y envoie de préférence les
sortants de prison donc d'ailleurs je me
demande pourquoi les sortants de prison
on ne fait pas le travail en amont à
savoir que les préfectures
iraient se ferait donner la liste des
gens ble d'être renvoyé dans leur pays
d'origine et ferait les démarches déjà
pourquoi on les envoie dans des centres
de rétention qui coûte 690 € par jour
par retenu et qui en
plus bah voilà et puis en plus ce
phénomène de de porte tournante qu'on a
repéré alors à Toulouse se à
bordeaugadignan à Perpignan à Nanterre
au baaette c'est-à-dire que les gens g
sortent du centre de rétention vous
savez que il y a que 10 % des TF qui
sont exécutés moins de 10 % même alors
c'est un peu plus
quand quand ça vient des centres de
rétention je crois que c'est 40 % des
gens qui partent mais Le Rest je ne
comprend pas sur quelle base légale on
retient des gens qui ne vont pas qui ne
vont jamais partir puis qu'il y a des
pays qui ne reprennent pas les
ressortissants jusqu'à ce que ce
comprenne que c'est une politique
affirmée par revendiquée par le ministre
de l'intérieur ils ne doivent pas sortir
donc donc prison on n pas je vous
rappelle ces services n'ont pas fait les
démarches dans les en amont on les
envoie dans les cras 690 € par jour on
les relâche du cras dans la nature donc
sans
rien et évidemment un procureur m'a dit
moi j'en ai assez de subir les les
pressions de la
préfecture qui semble combler les
défaillances du ministre de l'intérieur
des services de l'Intérieur puisque il
n'arrivve pas à renvoyer les gens donc
les gens qui sortent
de CR on me demande de les poursuivre
pour des faits que je ne poursuivrai pas
s'il s'agissait d'étranger avec papier
ou de français avec une
CNI voilà donc ils
commettent un deal un vol à l'ét je sais
pas ils sont renvoyés en prison ils y
passent de 3 mois et puis ça recommence
ils repartent au cras et voilà et
maintenant je pense avoir fait à peu
près le tour j'attendrai vos questions
pour approfondir et je vais laisser la
parole à André sur l'hôpital
psychiatrique en vitesse peut-être
ouais je suis trop bavarde Monsieur le
Secrétaire général allez-y merci
monsieur le
Président quelques mots sur les la
situation des hôpitaux psychiatriques je
rappelle naturellement que le cjlpl
n'est pas chargé de contrôler la
psychiatrie mais seulement les la
situation des patients en soin sans
consentement néanmoins cette situation
et les droits de ces patients sont ind
sociable du du contexte dans lequel ils
sont pris en charge l'élément majeur de
ce contexte c'est évidemment la crise
démographique que subissent les hôpitaux
psychiatriques c'est-à-dire la baisse du
nombre de personnel médical et
paramédical qui conduit à une
augmentation en volume de la contrainte
que ce soit le nombre des soins sans
consentement qui est en croissance pour
diverses raisons dont une est la
défaillance des des des systèmes de
prévention et notamment des soins
ambulatoires qui permettent de prévenir
la crise et cette situation de baisse
démographique
s'aggrave elle s'aggrave dans la plupart
des hôpitaux que nous visitons et elle
est plus grave encore en ce qui concerne
les services de pédopsychiatrie
puisqu'il y a en France plusieurs
départements qui n'ont pas de lit
d'hospitalisation en pédopsychiatrie ce
qui veut dire que les enfants placés en
dans ces dans ces département sont
hospitalisés avec des adultes dans des
structures qui ne sont pas adaptées à
leur prés en charge et qui ne sont même
pas adaptés à leur protection euh donc
aujourd'hui l'état de la situation est
assez grave comme vous le savez la
remontée en puiss en charge de la
psychiatrie est une un projet à très
longue haline puisqu'il s'agit de former
des médecins et c'est donc quelque chose
qui de notre point de vue demande qu'on
réinterroge le le modèle de de de la
psychiatrie actuelle hospitalococentré
avec un système de de fermeture de lit
d'hospitalisation complète qui précède
la mise en place des dispositifs
ambulatoires censés la remplacer alors
qu'il devrait plutôt la suivre puisque
dans l'intervalle de temps qui se
déroule entre ces deux phénomènes il y a
une crise de la prise en charge
il est il est question de plus en plus
de d'une nouvelle loi sur la psychiatrie
destinée à à mettre en place un nouveau
modèle de psychiatrie il y en a une
précédente en 1960 une au début des
années 90 et aujourd'hui on voit bien
que que les modèles ainsi constitués
sont en partie
obsolètes 2è sujet important sur la
psychiatrie c'est la suite qui a été
donnée à une loi que vous avez voté il y
a maintenant 2 ans sur le contrôle
juridictionnel des mesures de contrainte
cette loi peine beaucoup à se à se
mettre en place parce que à la fois du
côté
médical du côté judiciaire et surtout
entre les deux c'est-à-dire du côté des
systèmes
d'information les outils font défut les
outils de communication font défauts on
est dans des conditions de délais très
brèves donc des des des des des des
délais qui ne supportent pas l'échange
de cour ou qui ne supporte pas des
procédures d'information qui prennent un
peu de temps donc
aujourd'hui le le contrôle de de ces
mesures de soin sans consentement est
très inégale dans le ce que nous
observons dans nos contrôles très inégal
suivant les juridictions à Paris par
exemple nous avons
vu avec le tribunal judiciaire qu'il
était assez efficace puisque un
pourcentage significatif de de mesures
font l'objet de main levée dans certains
autres ressorts ce n'est pas du tout ce
n'est pas du tout la même chose
néanmoins je souhaite appeler votre
attention sur les lacunes que comporte
encore ce contrôle juridictionnel
puisqu'il y a un certain nombre de
mesures de psychiatrie qui échappent au
contrôle du juge en particulier le
placement dans unité pour malad
difficile et surtout l'ensemble de la
situation des enfants puisque les
enfants n'ont pas ne connaissent pas de
statut il n'y a pas de statut de
l'enfant hospitalisé
que ce soit en psychiatrie ou ailleurs
de sorte que les enfants qui sont en
soin libre ne sont pas censés être
placés à l'isolement et en contention et
pourtant le sont pour finir je voudrais
appeler votre attention sur un projet un
un sujet qui est en train de se
développer dans le dans le flou
juridique le plus total c'est ce qu'on
appelle les unités de soins intensif en
psychiatrie ce sont des objets nouveaux
qui n'ont aucun statut ni réglementaire
ni même par circulaire et qui sont euh
euh soin intensif en psychiatrie ça veut
pas dire que les soins sont plus
intensifs ça veut dire que la contrainte
est plus forte euh c'est c'est une forme
de d'une forme de langage détourné sur
le sur le sujet et et donc ces unités de
soins intensifs qui sont des unités
d'enfermement dans laquelle il n'y a que
des patients soin sans consentement se
développe en l'absence de tout statut en
l'absence de toute politique
d'affectation des patients et surtout en
l'absence de tout contrôle
juridictionnel alors que euh le simple
placement dans cette unité est
évidemment fortement restrictif de droit
euh voilà ce que je voulais euh des
points sur lesquels je souhaitais
appeler votre attention en ce qui
concerne l'état de la psychiatrie tel
qu'il ressort de nos visites de 2022 et
de celles qui se sont poursuivies en
début
2023 merci moi j'avais j'avais trois
questions avant de passer la parole à
mes collègues euh qui portent davantage
sur la situation estivale des
établissements pénitenties
que sur le rapport que vous avez commis
mais je pense que vous pouvez me
répondreis rapport que vous avez commis
c'est ainsi qu'on le dit et et donc et
donc sur la question de la situation de
la prison de Bordeaux graguignan qui a
une alors on prend toutes les question
laassoation de la prison de Bordeau
garignon qui a une une suroccupation de
240 % cet été qui a conduit à un stop
écrou donc un processus quasiment
spontané de régulation carcérale je
voulais savoir si vous avez eu des
relations avec la directrice Inter
régionale de du SPIP si ensuite il y a
eu des conseils de votre part dans
l'accompagnement de cette procédure et
si vous avez mesuré les effets sur
l'établissements directement Connex je
pense notamment aux transferts qui ont
eu lieu à vivon puisque c'est à vivon on
a constaté ensuite dans la période
estivale et principalement au mois
d'août à la prison de vivon centre
pénitentiaire de 700 détenus trois
suicides et donc si c'est la conséquence
directe de ces transférements ce que moi
j'estime être le cas et ensuite si vous
avez des établissements pilotes ou que
vous jugez comme tel dans le déploiement
des politiques de santé mentale puisque
vous avez dit ce qui ce qui peut être le
vrai qu'on a une une surreprésentation
des personnes malades en prison en tout
cas atteint de trouble psychiatrique et
ce qu'on voit dans certains
établissements et notamment le centre
pénitentiaire de vivon auquel je me suis
rendu il y a quelques quelques jours euh
il y a une vraie volonté avec des
établissements spécialisés comme les
centres hospitaliers en psychiatrie de
de d'avoir une vraie action qui
qu'entraîne quand même presque 80
consultations journalières euh au
service psychiatrique interne donc dans
l'établissement pénitentiaes donc ça ça
m'intéresse de savoir si vous avez
repéré des bonnes pratiques dernière
question il y a la question du travail
que vous avez évoqué comme comme
solution en tout cas comme processus qui
permet la réinsertion des détenus et qui
permet finalement de faire aussi
redescendre la pression dans
l'établissement pénitentiè est-ce que
vous constatez avec les nouvelles
législations que vous avez salué par
rapport au contrat de travail et à la
rémunération des détenus et aux droits
qui leur sont octroyés sur les
cotisations social notamment est-ce que
vous constatez une amélioration de la
situation notamment du point de vue de
la marge de progression et la la
possibilité d'avoir de plus en plus de
détenus travailleurs puisque c'est ce
que vous avez pointé comme étant
l'exemple notamment l'exemple allemand
ça c'est les questions que j'ai posé
après je pose des questions directement
des collègues on fait une vague de 10
j'ai pres 20 inscrits donc on aura de
quoi faire différentes vagues la
première question sera posée par Madame
Caroline Abadi pour 2 minutes chacune
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
la contrôleur générale des lieux de
privation de liberté vos avis nous font
rarement plaisir évidment ément
puisqu'il pointe que ce soit en santé
mentale dans les cras ou en détention
des situations que nous que nous
déplorons également que nous pouvons
constater nous-mêmes sur le terrain j'ai
noté toutefois que vous à chaque fois
dans vos dans vos rapports vous essayez
aussi de de de distribuer des
encouragements les efforts qu'on a pu
faire sur la codification du droit
pénitentiaire les efforts qu'on a fait
sur le statut du travailleur en
détention le déploiement aussi de la
téléphonie tout ça vous vous le saluez
j'en cite quelques-uns mais pas tout
avec des efforts et des nuances ne me
regardez pas comme ça mais on on on on
apprécie que vous ayez des des avis qui
puissent être nuancés qui encouragent
nos nos nos propres efforts alors oui on
connaît la situation ça fait 30 ans
qu'il y a une surpopulation en en en
maison d'arrêt particulièrement dans
notre pays monsieur le président l'a
rappelé à Gradignan cette année 240 %
tau d'occupation qui amène hors cadre
légal des personnels pénitentiaes à
fermer les portes pendant quelques
semaines euh au prix au prix
effectivement peut-être de conséquences
géographiques mais en tout cas pour
éviter probablement une mutinerie qui
était là qui était là dans les les les
semaines à venir la surpopulation c'est
pas juste des mètres carrés c'est aussi
des effectifs des activités et on peut
pas aujourd'hui imaginer réinsérer avec
cette oisiveté en prison qui est presque
imposée alors nous on a plaidé depuis
plusieurs années hein la la création de
de 15000 PL de prison mais en même temps
on a aussi fait en sorte de développer
les alternatives parce que pour nous les
deux les deux aller ensemble d'autant
que les alternatives souvent permettent
une meilleure réinsertion et à un
meilleur coût alors face à à tous ces
efforts pourtant on peut que constater
cette surpopulation chronique et on en
arrive avec quelques-uns de nos
collègues à constater qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la responsabilité du politique le
politique ne peut pas regarder
impuissamment ce constat et doit
aujourd'hui programmer la réduction de
la surpopulation carcérale merci Madame
Elsa
fossillon ça me paraît logique de vous
donner la parole à toutes les deux
rapporteurs de la mission d'information
sur le sujet merci
beaucoup juste que je retrouve mon
document merci excusez-moi du coup
j'étais pas
ouis un peu troublé merci quand même
monsieur le le Président Madame Simono
merci beaucoup pour pour vos
interventions évidemment mon
intervention sera moins une question
qu'un relais des travaux menés avec
Madame Abad mais j'ai le sentiment aussi
un un relais préconisation formulée dans
dans votre rapport vous parlez
d'ailleurs du d'une inertie coupable
face à la surpopulation vous parlez
aussi de de calcul à court terme sans
vision ni réalisme répondant au
populisme par des incantation et des
roulements de biceps et cela la société
toute entière n'a pas fini de le payer
très cher je reprends vos propos parce
qu'il me semble raisonner très justement
avec ce que nous avons à produire
aujourd'hui y compris dans cette
commission c'est-à-dire lutter contre
des instrumentalisations euh contre des
fausses informations euh et contre une
volonté qui nous éloigne de du sens de
la prison et du sens que nous sommes
censés donner à la prison pour qu'elle
rende service à la société toute entière
pas simplement qu'elle rende service au
détenu mais même si c'est une volonté
que nous pouvons assumer c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut que quand les détenus sortent
de cette prison et bien nous sachions et
bien à la fois qu'ils ont exécuté leur
peine mais aussi et bien qu'ils sont en
capacité de se réinsérer dans cette
société et donc lutter contre la
récidive et que c'est en luttant contre
cette surpopulation carcérale que nous
pouvons y aider pas seulement nous avons
aussi besoin de surveillant et
d'ailleurs vous pointez cette réalité du
déficit de de surveillant qui est
calculé sur les effectifs théoriques et
pas sur sur les des effectifs réels vous
dénoncez aussi et bien le manque de
prise en charge des des troubles
psychiatriques et donc au travers de de
plusieurs préconisations avec Madame
Abadi à la fois retrouver le sens de la
peine lutter contre le le tout carcéral
mais un mécanisme aussi contraignant
nous pensons que c'est allé dans le bon
sens et c'est allé dans un sens de la
peine retrouverver monsieuran gilet
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la contrôleure générale les
établissements pénitentiaires
connaissent une surpopulation importante
les statistiques officielles montrent
que la situation s'aggrave du fait de l'
saagement de notre société violence
contre les agents pénitentiaires
agression entre détenus
dysfonctionnement les conséquences de la
surpopulation carcérale sont nombreuses
la solution nous la connaissons tous il
faut construire des prisons mais forcé
de constater que là aussi le
gouvernement échoue je tiens à souligner
le travail remarquable et le profession
nationalisme des surveillants
pénitentiaires ils effectuent un travail
difficile et sont les premières victimes
de cette surpopulation les dernières
données disponibles font émerger 12
agressions par jour de d'agents
pénitentiaires nos agents pénitentiaires
premières victimes de la surpopulation
carcéral je le disais sont par ailleurs
en effectif insuffisant cette situation
n'est plus tenable et je me demande bien
quand il y aura une prise de conscience
en la matière madame la contrôleur
générale en 2022 vos visites
d'établissement pénitentiaires dont
celui de NIM sur ma circonscription
semble se limiter assez largement à
l'appréciation des conditions de vie des
détenus il me semble que votre travail
s'il faisait s'il ne faisait pas pardon
l'impasse sur les conditions de travail
difficiles des surveillants
pénitentiaire pourrait enfin être un
temps soit peu crédible votre rapport
d'activité 2022 parle des conditions de
détention des recours excessifs aux
fouilles de la gestion sécuritaire
attentatoire au droit mais vous semblez
omettre les premières victimes de cette
surpopulation comment d'ailleurs pointer
les fouilles excessives quand l'on
connaît la réalité anime toujours et
pour rappel un surveillant avait été
agressé par un détenu avec une lame de
rasoir et avait eu la gorge tranchée sur
8 cm ma question est simple pourquoi le
sort des personnel de l'administration
pénitentiaire est-il si absent de votre
rapport pourquoi aucune de vos
recommandations ne vont sur ce thème
pourquoi madame quand je vous écoute
aije l'impression d'entendre un député
de la nupes
merci Madame le dit jaquier la
[Musique]
forge merci monsieur le Président Madame
la contrôleur général je suis une
nouvelle fois allée au centre
pénitentiaire de Grenoble Vars avec le
bâtonnier de Grenoble la semaine
dernière nous sommes nombreux en iser à
avoir effectivement interpellé le garde
des saau sur l'état de vetusté
de cet
établissement c'est l'ensemble du
système pénitentiaire en France qui est
dans une situation critique hein vous
l'avez vous l'avez rappelé à la suite de
la condamnation de la France par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme cet été
et cet établissement ne ne fait pas ne
fait pas
exception en fait mon intervention
aujourd'hui c'est pour souligner comme
l'a fait ma collègue Caroline Abadi
cette volonté politique qui a été
marquée par un engagement fort de
nouvelles places de prison pour indiquer
que cette volonté politique elle est
bien évidemment nationale mais elle doit
être aussi soutenue euh par les élus
locaux et la nécessité de ce nouvel
établissement se fait sentir notamment
par euh cette surpopulation endémique
euh mais aussi par un établissement euh
qui arrive vraiment euh en fin de vie eu
on a le mur de la promenade qui a dû
être consolidé puisqu'il était en train
de de s'effondrer euh on a une zone qui
n'est pas au norme pour les personnes
qui sont dans le quartier disciplinaire
et donc je crois que cette volonté elle
doit être bien évidemment celle de notre
commission et nous sommes nombreux à
nous rendre dans les lieux de privation
de de liberté et nous exerçons nos
missions collectivement de façon très
attentive et je terminerai en remerciant
le personnel
pénitentiaire
puisque à chaque fois on voit la
de ces hommes et de ces femmes qui
travaillent dans des conditions
difficiles je vous remercie merci
Monsieur HUG
bernalissis merci monsieur le Président
je vais venir au renfort effectivement
des des argumentations sur les questions
de la la régulation carcérale parce
qu'il faut reposer quand même rapidement
le le constat on a eu des lois
successives et et dans laaviture
précédente notamment la loi de
programmation de de la justice qui avait
pour intention pas juste de construire
des nouvelles place de prison mais aussi
de limiter les incarcérations c'est
objectif affiché et notamment de limiter
les courtes peines force de constater
que cette loi n'a pas produit les effets
escomptés puisqu'on a un accroissement
du nombre de de personnes détenues
d'ailleurs sur 30 ans les lois successif
qui visaient à proposer des alternatives
à l'incarcération n'ont fait qu'en
réalité augmenter la la la le nombre de
personnes au total dedans et dehors
placé sous sous main de sous main de
justice euh donc c'est abord d'abord un
constat un constat d'échec et pour notre
déshonneur à toutes et à tous c'est 2383
matelas au sol que nous avons dans dans
ce pays dans dans nos dans nos prisons
évidemment
euh je n'ai pas changé d'avis et mon
groupe non plus sur le l'enjeu d'abord
et avant tout d'une déflation pénale
pour atteindre ses objectifs néanmoins
forc de constater que le la la majorité
politique pour ça n'existe pas ce jour à
7hure à l'Assemblée nationale mais que
tout le monde constate que les
conditions de travail des uns sont les
conditions de vie des autres et
inversement et que du coup il y a un
enjeu à à faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
pas de surpopulation y compris en l'état
actuel de la situation et de la
politique pénale dès lors le mécanisme
de régulation carcérale apparaît comme
le plus indiqué pour contenter tout le
monde quel que soit son option son
opinion politique qu'on pense qu'il
faille construire des places de prison
ou pas n'a pas d'incidence et d'impact
sur le mécanisme de régulation carcérale
je le dis pour essayer de faire
converger ce sujet et qu'on qu'on
attienne évidemment une une une majorité
donc le mécanisme de régulation
carcérale semble s'imposer un petit peu
à la fois de ceux qui ont regardai la
question de prês comme une évidence
est-ce que et ma question sera la
suivante où en êtes-vous des des
relations des discussions avec le le
gouvernement l'administration de
pénitentiaire et et quels sont
aujourd'hui les Alliés institutionnels y
compris dans la magistrature qui se sont
déclarés favorables à ce à ce mécanisme
monsieur
Solignac merci monsieur le Président
Madame la la contrôleure générale merci
pour les travaux que vous menez je
voudrais vous poser une question qui est
peut-être un peu à la limite de votre
périmètre de contrôle puisque s'agissant
de la psychiatrie vous traitez
essentiellement de ceux qui reçoent
soivent des soins sans consentement et
moi je voudrais vous parler de
l'hospitalisation psychiatrique à
domicile qui va croissante avec et pour
les raisons qu'on connaît beaucoup moins
onéreuse pour la sécurité sociale mais
elle se traduit par un suivi de moins
bonne qualité avec un lien très distendu
entre le patient et les soignants on
voit même voir même parfois des patients
qui finissent par disparaître des radars
des établissements et donc je voudrais
savoir si vous avez observé des sorties
du régime de
hospitalisation dont on peut penser
qu'elles sont motivées par le besoin si
vous me permettez l'expression le besoin
de faire de la place ou d'alléger la
charge de travail dans des services
psychiatriques qui sont en sous-effectif
chronique j'ai conscience que ma
question est un peu paradoxale puisque
si je devais la résumer est-ce
qu'onaccorde pas dans certains cas des
libertés au détriment des
soins monsieur Benjamin
Lucin merci merci monsieur le Président
Madame la contrôleur générale merci pour
évidemment votre rapport et et et les
constats que vous évoquez qui sont
bouleversants quandbien même nous
connaissons ce qui est notre cas déjà la
réalité moi je voulais vous vous
interroger rapidement sur la situation
de l'enseignement en en prison sur à la
fois les contraintes pesants sur
l'accessibilité de l'enseignement et sur
vos préconisations pour que le
législateur puisse les alléger dans
l'objectif de rendre effectif ce droit à
à l'enseignement sur la situation
d'accès à l'enseignement dans les
établissements pénitentiaires pour
mineurs là aussi sur ce que pourrait
être vos vos préconisations et sur euh
les lacunes éventuelles de l'action
gouvernementale en matière de droit
d'accès à l'enseignement et et savoir si
de votre point de vue elles sont le fait
d'une absence de de moyens ou de normes
de contraintte que nous pourrions lever
par notre action législative je vous
remercie Monsieur Jean
Terlier merci Monsieur le le président
madame la contrôleur générale des des
lieux de privation de liberté peut-être
un un mot en en en préambule quand
j'entends du du côté de de de certaines
de nos oppositions le le fait de venir
dire que ce gouvernement cette majorité
ne ferait pas le nécessaire en matière
de de construction de prison et puis
dans le même temps j'allais dire ces
même députés qui votent le la loi de
programmation à justice qui inscrit dans
le dur la réalisation de d'un plan
ambitieux de de 15000 constructions de
de de place de
prison oui 15000 on ira 18000 si on
arrive à faire d'abord les les premiers
15000 vous avez raison de vous vous avez
raison de vous avez raison de le
préciser peut-être sur euh vous
interrogez sur ce que vous avez évoqué
sur la question des des CF euh j'allais
dire que je je partage avec vous ce que
ce que vous avez euh évoqué sur sur les
centres éducatifs fermés euh Rappelz que
ces établissements euh permettent
d'accueillir euh 8 à à 12 mineurs avec
des professionnels qui sont au nombre de
27 que ces CF constitue une alternative
à la prison et et et vous l'avez dit et
je pense que c'est euh intéressant aussi
euh que certains de mes collègues
l'entendent que ça fonctionne bien que
ça fonctionne bien quand on a une équipe
éducative qui est performante et un
encadrement euh dédié qui qui permet
justement de de faire fonctionner euh
ces ces CF vous avez aussi dit je je
reprends vos mots on voudrait voir les
enfants y rester plus longtemps je
partage partiellement ce ce ce constat
avec vous peut-être de dire que je
trouve que les les mineurs délincant
vont peut-être un peu trop tardivement
dans ces structuresl où ils y reçoivent
un encandrement et et des et des mesures
et des mesures appropriées alors
peut-être une question sur sur ce sujet
peut-être pour nous aider à avancer vous
savez qu'il y a un plan ambitieux de de
réalisation de CF dans le cadre de cette
mandature et de la précédente peut-être
nous indiquer nous faire part des des
mesures qui seraient les votes pour
justement que ce soit l'ensemble des des
centres éducatifs fermés qui
fonctionnent de manière de manière très
correcte merci merci Madame Elvis
Diaz merci Monsieur le présid président
madame la contrôleur générale des lieux
de privation de liberté ce qui attire
l'attention à lecture de vos différents
rapports d'activité c'est la constance
de votre constat au sujet de la
surpopulation carcérale que personne ne
conteste c'est ainsi que chaque année on
lit vos mêmes recommandations
dénonciation condamnation et
préconisation la surpopulation carcérale
est une question sur laquelle vous
travaillez depuis longtemps puisqu'en
2004 lorsque vous étiez journaliste chez
libération vous lanciez déjà l'alerte et
vous parliez de surpopulation carcérale
en en ces termes c'est au-delà du pire
sauf qu'en 2007 l'autorité
administrative indépendante que vous
dirigez depuis 2020 a été créé et elle
est dotée d'un budget important 6
million d'euros pour 2023 et une
augmentation d'un million d'euros depuis
2020 un commentaire sur les propositions
que vous formulez à savoir suspendre les
incarcérations et vider les prisons
elles ne sont pas souhaitables lorsqu'on
s'intéresse comme le rassemblement
national à la sécurité des Français et à
la reconstruction des victimes mais ce
qui interpelle c'est que vous dénoncez
l'inertie du gouvernement or après 15
ans d'existence une facture élevée pour
les finances public et des résultats
dérisoires en matière de prise en compte
des recommandations j'ai deux questions
comment vous justifiez l'utilité de
votre instance et que répondez-vous à
ceux qui pensent que vous vous
accommodez plutôt bien de la situation
des prisons puisque'au final elle assure
la pérennité de votre fond de
commerce madame madame Elisa Martin
hein bonjour je vous remercie beaucoup
de vous
être approché de nous pour qu'on puisse
avoir ce temps de travail commun euh le
12 juillet j'étais à la frontière
franco-italienne donc à
Menton et j'ai pu avec mon équipe
parlementaire entrer dans un lieu qui
est dit euh lieu de mise à l'abri ce
lieu et sans encadrement juridique on y
contraint à rester un certain nombre de
personnes sans droit ni titre et bien
sûr ce lieu est aujourd'hui situé à
l'intérieur des locaux de la PAF donc
ils sont retenu de la police de l'AR des
frontières ils sont retenus donc des
femmes des enfants des majeurs j'insiste
sans aucun cadre juridique en gros au
motif que la frontière italienne est
administrative
fermé et en particulier elle est fermée
la nuit donc pour pouvoir renvoyer les
personnes puisque c'est une sorte pardon
c'est très trivial de jeux de ping-pong
donc pour pouvoir renvoyer les personnes
vers la frontière italienne et bien on
les enferme on est d'accord sur ce terme
à partir du moment où c'est fermé à clé
et à partir du moment où votre liberté
d'aller et venir et et est on est bien
dans un lieu dans un lieu
d'enfermement ce que nous av avons pu
constater c'est avant toute chose
évidemment outre le caractère
d'enfermement du lieu que les lieux ne
sont évidemment pas
adapté pour accueillir toutes ces
personnes et notre inquiétude don des
enfants et des femmes et des femmes
enceintes et cetera donc notre
inquiétude est d'autant plus renforcée
que j'ai cru comprendre et nous avons
cru comprendre au travers des propos de
Monsieur darvanin qui est le ministre de
l'Intérieur qu'il comptait bien élargir
ce lieu et pouvoir y priver de liberté
de 100 personnes donc moi la la question
que j'ai envie de vous poser je vois que
vous vous connaissez ce lieu c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez faire pour le fermer
merci donc vous avez la parole pour les
réponses à la question des collègues
sachant que j'ai encore inscrits pour
une seconde vague de
questions alors monsieur le Président je
commence par vous n'est-ce pas euh le
stopécou de Perpignan de Grad de
Gradignan pardon et bien oui j'ai été en
contact avec tout le monde bien sûr je
suis tombée sur des
professionnels désespérés de la prison
et ce
stopécrou il a été décidé il a été fixé
à 190 % cétait quand même un objectif
modeste c'estàdire que il devait être
décidé quand la prison dès que la prison
atteignait les 190 % d'occupation et
finalement il n'a été déclenché qu'à 230
%. euh je peux vous dire que à Gradignan
particulièrement
euh c'est là que j'ai rencontré avec
prepignant d'ailleurs les les les
personnels les les agents pénitentiaires
les plus désespérés
et j'y reviendrai plus tard pour
répondre à la question qui ou au
reproches qui m'a été adressé euh je me
soucie particulièrement et on se soucie
particulièrement de la vie des
surveillants et on ne cesse de dire
d'ailleurs que leur sort le sort des
détenus et des surveillants en ce qui
concerne ce ce ce problème est lié euh
la psychiatrie en
prison ben enfin vous voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est quand même un
stopécrw qui avait été fixé par
convention à 190 % et qui n'est
déclenché qu'à 230
%
c'est c'est pas ce qu'on peut attendre
de de plus enthousiasment hein et
ensuite effectivement le problème c'est
quand ça n'est pas national c'est local
alors évidemment ça se déverse sur les
prison d'à côté et Poitier vivon
oui il y a un nombre de suicides très
très inquiétant dans cette prison et sur
ce qui est de la psychiatrie en
prison
son accès il est restreint alors moi là
vous me dites il y a beaucoup de il y a
plein de gens qui prennent plein de
détenus qui prennent rendez-vous moi je
peux vous citer des endroits où
malheureusement ils prennent rendez-vous
d'ailleurs on en a parlé hier avec le
délégué
ministériel à la au plan
psychiatrie qui nous dit que il a vu des
endroits et et nos contrôleurs ont vu
des endroits où il y a 30
inscrits pour la journée et il y a
quatre détenus qui vient
voilà et c'est vrai qu'à Poitier il y a
il y a un
service un service psychiatrique donc
c'est vrai que ça doit marcher un peu
mieux mais voyez ça n'empêche pas les
conditions de détenenstion sont telles
que comme je vous le dis c'est cette
impression d'abandon de l'État à la fois
des surveillants et des détenus et des
et des médecins et je vous rappelle que
les les surveillants et les médecins
sont contingentés selon le le nombre
théorique de place et non selon le
nombre de prisonniers ce qui est quand
même logiquement un peu je sais pas
comment dire mais c'est pas très
intelligent
quoi tu voulais ajouter un mot sur la
psychiatrie en prison André non simple
simplement pour dire qu' il y a de deux
vitesses d'accès à la psychiatrie en
prison il y a les établissements qui
sont dotés d'un service
médico-psychologique régional et les
autres euh dans la dans la première
catégorie contrairement à ce que le nom
du service en question indique c'est un
service qui fonctionne principalement
quand même au bénéfice des détenus de
l'établissement euh et dans les autres
établissements on on est on est réduit à
faire appel au servicees psychiatrique
de proximité et je vous renvoie
là-dessus à ce que je dis de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure de l'état des
établissements de santé
mentale
alors madame Abad certes c'est vrai que
on s'est vraiment félicité du de la
codification dans le droit pénitentiaire
du droit du travail de la codification
du droit pénitentiaire en général bon le
salaire distribué reste quand même un
peu en dessous de la main j'ai récemment
d'autre part croisé un
professeur dans qui était prof dans une
maison d'arrêt et qui a abandonné parce
que il lui fallait à peu près 2 he pour
rentrer dans la prison et ça je signale
que c'est un motif de découragement
aussi des entreprises qui seraient
susceptible d'apporter du travail aux
détenus
euh c'est les normes de de sécurité sont
peut-être exagéré je vois pas pourquoi
en Allemagne c'est plus facile je prends
toujours cet exemple je ne crois pas que
l'Allemagne soit un exemple de laxisme
pénitentiare ni ni pénal et je crois pas
qu'il y ait un taux de récidif supérieur
à ici au contraire même simplement on
croit plus au hors les murs en
Allemagne la téléphonie installée dans
les cellules certes nous nous en
félicitons
mais je signale quand même qu'il y a un
prix parce que ces téléphones ont été
installés gratuitement dans les cellules
mais l'entreprise stéios se rembourse
sur les communications passées par les
détenus et ces communications coûtent un
prix dingue et l'exemple le plus
frappant est celui de l'outrem les
prisons d'outrem pour appeler quelqu'un
dans la même île que soi on repasse par
la métropole et ça revient et ça coûte
trois fois plus cher encore que les
conversations
entre de métropole à métropole c'est
quand même un peu étrange donc la
téléphonie bah on s'en félicite mais un
peu de loin si vous voulez parce que on
enquête même là-dessus pour sortir un
avis le stop et
crou le stopcw bah je viens de le dire
c'est tant que ça reste local
le vous stoppez les incarcérations là
vous les augmentez ailleurs donc tant
que ce sera pas un mécanisme national je
je n'y crois
guerre alors vous avez parlé du plan
euh pour nous nous ne sommes pas pour la
construction de prison on est plus pour
des des façons d'exécuter les peines
autres euh mais surtout ce plan 15000
nous paraît totalement illusoire et je
vous renvoie à au remarquable rapport de
votre collègue Patrick
etsel avec qui j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger et qui explique comment en
plusieurs gouvernements successifs on a
eu des annonces de plan 15000 qui ne se
sont jamais réalisés là on avait un plan
15000 annoncé en 2017 qui ne s'est
toujours pas réalisé pour le moment on a
3000 places nettes sorties de terre et
encore la maison d'arrêt de lterb avait
été annoncé par Michel aliomarie en 2008
donc je P qui fait partie des 3000
places
donc je ne sais pas comment vous dire on
verra en
2027 ça n'a pas empêché et dans inscrire
3000 de plus mais il paraît que ça
compte pas j'ai je n'ai pas vos habit
voilà
merci paraît que c'est 3000 de plus oui
PZ en commander
euh voilà
et c'est vrai que c'est vrai que comme
vous je pense que il en va de la
responsabilité politique du gouvernement
et de l'assemblée et des parlementaires
de décider ce que vous ferez des prisons
et et ce que vous ce que vous en ferez
si vous mettez en place un mécanisme qui
permettent que la prison que la peine
serve à quelque chose je ne parle pas
euh
euh de la loi qui fait que qui nous
oblige à nous le contrôle général à
vérifier que les droits fondamentaux des
détenus et d'autres personnes sont
respectés mais je parle simplement de
façon pragmatique il faudrait que la
prison serve à quelque chose et la seule
façon c'est qu'il ait pas de plus de
détenus que de place ça me paraît tomber
sous le sens et et je vous dire
rapportez-vous allez visiter les prisons
allemande vous verrez ce qu'il en est
ben madame fussillon oui je parle on
parle d'inertie coupable euh et encore
une fois de l'État en ce qui concerne
les lieux de privation de liberté et
d'un abandon à la fois des
fonctionnaires chargés de soigner je le
répète soigner et garder les détenus et
de et et des et des personnes enfermées
elles-mêmes
euh voilà je crois que j'ai répondu en
partie à ce que vous disiez sur le sens
de la peine à
retrouver que il y a un déficit de
surveillant
c'est un déficit
effrayant là moi j'ai j'ai beaucoup de
relations avec l'administration je dis
je nous avons beaucoup de relations avec
l'administration pénitentiaire beaucoup
de relations avec les directeurs des
prisons moi je dis toujours sur les
fiches de poste des directeurs il y a
pas marqué recherche Superman pour
diriger prison ingérable or c'est
exactement le cas je comprend pas
comment ils font les directeurs là c'est
ingérable ce qu'on leur met dans les
mains et les surveillants c'est c'est
dans du même
acabi déficit de surveillant voilà je
crois monsieur
gilet je je sais pas si vous avez
l'impression que d'entendre parler
quelqu'un de la nupes quand je parle
mais je crois que vous n'avez pas lu
notre
rapport parce que au moins dans deux
paragraphes j'aborde le non de
l'avant-propos qui fait trois pages je
parle d'abord la loi nous oblige à
vérifier les droits fondamentaux des
détenus puisque vous parlez des
surveillants ensuite les surveillants je
n'arrête pas d'en parler en disant qu'on
les abandonne également que ils nous
confient leur détresse leur désespoir
et je vous conseille je vous conseille
peut-être de le lire c'est si ça vous
est pas trop pénible comme lecture
euh je je trouve voilà et et je n on
n'arrête pas de le répéter et d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour dire que nous avons
reçu au contrôle général un travail qui
aurait pu être fait par d'autres sans
doute mais au moins 30 organisations
pénitentièes
pénitentiaire syndicat de syndicat
pénitentiaire d'avocats de magistrat
judiciire et
administratif de
médecins de et
d'association justement pour faire le
point sur ce qu'il en est du sens de la
peine de de la situation des prisons et
on a été tous d'accord pour dire ça ne
peut plus durer cette désagrégation du
service pénitentiaire de la justice sous
nos yeux sans rien faire ne peut pas
durer je pense que vous la
représentation nationale devriez y
prendre
part
tu veux dire quelque
chose simplement rappeler que le le
CGLPL est une autorité instituée par la
loi et qui exerce son mandat dans le
cadre fixé par la loi et ce cadre fixé
par la loi vous pouvez le consulter les
débats parlementaires ce que nous avons
fait sur ce sujet lorsque nous avons eu
un litige sur la question du statut du
personnel avec le garde des saut qui
daignait notre compétence à parler du
personnel la loi fixe comme mandat au
CGLPL de veiller au respect des droits
fondamentaux des personnes privées de
liberté et expressément dans les débats
parlementaires qui ont précédé
l'adoption de la loi du 30 octobre 2007
la question de la compétence du CGLPL
sur la sur la situation du personnel a
été abordée et elle a été écartée
explicitement par le
Parlement
pour vous dire que justement demain
sortiront sur cette même prison des
recommandation en urgence tellement la
situation que nous y avons trouvé est
épouvantable c'était l'exemple dont on
se servait toujours Grenoble c'est la
convention de de régulation carcérale
entre personnes de bî de volonté que
sont le personnel de la maison d'arrêt
la direction les les services
pénitentiaires les services
judiciaires et puis il a suffit que deux
personnes de bonne volonté soient muté
pour que le mécanisme se casse la figure
et qu'on soit remonté à 176 % au moment
de notre visite et donc voilà c'est
comme vous l'avez remarqué c'est une
situation catastrophique et sur mur de
promenade en plus qui menaçait de
s'ffondré vous avez dû le voir je
signale ce sont des détenus qui
s'appuyant contre le mur ont dû signaler
à la direction qu'il est qui menaçait de
s'écrouler sinon sans eux il serait
peut-être
écroulé alors oui monsieur
bernalicis les les lois successives n'y
ont rien fait donc nous nous
attendons oui que ce ce mécanisme de
régulation soit inscrit dans la loi
euh comme bah je pense que là il y a
beaucoup de voix qui se font entendre
justement sur le sujet outre ces 30 si
vous voulez moi je suis très fière qu'on
ait pu réunir au CGLPL ces 30
organisations sont des gens qui ne se
parle pas souvent parfois qui refusent
même de se parler et qui se sont parlés
pour constater la même chose ça ne peut
plus durer donc faut bien faire quelque
chose voilà et c'est pour ça que je je
rebondis sur mes relations avec nos
relations avec l'administration
pénitentiaire et tous les acteurs de de
la chaîne pénale je crois avoir répondu
puis elles sont je dis pas quotidiennes
mais elles sont au moins deux fois par
semaine trois fois enfin elles sont très
fréquentes on échange avec
eux voilà sur la psychiatrie je te
laisse répondre André ou alors tu as à
Monsieur solign
oui merci euh la question des
hospitalisations à domicile ne relève
pas en
effet ne relève pas de la compét du
CGLPL néanmoins il y a deux éléments de
réflexion que je peux apporter à votre
assemblé sur ce point le premier c'est
que parmi les fonctions du CGLPL il y a
celle aussi de se référer à un corpus
juridique qui n'est pas le corpus
franco-français mais qui est également
celui des Nations Unies et dans le
corpus des Nations Unies un des
objectifs de la prise en charge
psychiatrique qui d'ailleurs ne relève
pas d'une prise en charge de
hospitalière mais une prise en charge
médico-sociale l'un des objectifs c'est
la
désinstitutionnalisation c'est-à-dire la
prise en charge par des soin ambulatoire
en second en second lieu sur la question
de l'hospitalisation à domicile toujours
ce que nous constatons de manière
systématique c'est que la qualité des
soins ambulatoires a un effet direct sur
la prévention des crises et que donc le
développement des soins ambulatoires en
psychiatrie et de toute forme de prise
en charge en milieu ouvert est une forme
de prévention du nombre de la croissance
du nombre des soins sans consentement il
y a en France un certain nombre de
services dont le principal le plus connu
est à lîle euh qui pratique un
développement très élevé de cette prise
en charge ambulatoire et on observe que
ça permet de prévenir très efficacement
la crise donc de faire baisser la
contrainte alors je réponds maintenant à
Monsieur Lucas sur une question qui
m'intéresse profondément et merci de
l'avoir posé comme on dit non euh chez
vous euh
sur l'enseignement en prison et dans les
centres éducatifs fermés
on on a beaucoup insisté là-dus dans
dans notre rapport justement parce que
c'est effrayant de constater que les
enfants enfermés ont 4 à 5 à si fois
moins d'Ur d'enseignement que leurs
camarades de dehors l'enseignement en
prison et en centre éducatif fermé ça ne
va pas du tout et or c'est c'est
consternant de constater que chez des
enfants qu'on de devrait prendre à bras
le corps justement parce qu'ils vont
grandir parce que c'est notre avenir à
tous ces enfants aussi et que on ne fait
pas ce qu'il faut écoutez il y a pas de
statut de prof spécial de professeurs
sans vacances scolaires c'est-à-dire que
les vacances scolaires sont
appliquées y compris dans les lieux
d'enfermement un enfant un gosse qui
rentre en prison en juin et en sort en
octobre n'a pas eu une demi-heure
d'enseignement euh c'est les les
responsables dans locaux d'enseignement
dans les prisons nous disent qu'ils sont
obligés de se débrouiller de 1000 façons
pour arriver à goupiller qui a assez
d'heur qui a un peu plus d'heur que mais
que ça tient à la personnalité du du du
chef d'établissement à qui avec qui il
faut se débrouiller et je vous conseille
pour ça de parler d'ailleurs à eo
direction pénitentiaire euh qui sont don
c'est un des un des choix de bataille ce
statut spécial et également un
un alors que c'est c'est l'année de la
grande cause de l'éducation euh le fait
d'une une loi qui rattache cette
l'éducation nationale en à l'éducation
nationale de dehors l'éducation
nationale en prison parce que pour le
moment ça n'est qu'une convention qui
liit la pénitentiaire à la à l'éducation
nationale et il faudrait faire mieux
pour que pour faire plus et pour faire
mieux et dans les centres éducatifs
fermés aussi c'est quand même aberérrant
que ces enfants plus fragiles que
d'autres
plus
voilà donc parfaitement d'accord
euh
bah sur la construction des ambitieus de
des 15000 places je crois avoir répondu
puisqu'il me faut aller vite et sur les
centres éducatifs fermés je vous ai dit
nos réserves à condition si on a visité
un centre qui était dans un état
épouvantable un centre éducatif on a
fait des recommandations et cetera bon
un an plus tard c'est sans doute à
inscrire à notre bilan dérisoire les
choses avaient changé le le la la
direction avait pris les choses en main
euh repris les choses en main disons et
ce centre éducatif fermé marche de façon
formidable mais pourquoi parce qu'ils
ont recréé et ils ont trouvé les moyens
de trouver une équipe pérenne solide
peut-être mieux payé la direction s'est
resserrée ils ont resserré leurs projets
et ça marche très bien donc si on vont
construire de nouveaux CF il faut en
prendre les moyens et créer c ça sert à
rien de servir d'alibi de dire on
enferme ces enfants là on les voit plus
ça n'est qu'un alibi dans des dans des
centres éducatifs fermés qui March mal
faute de personnel compétent et formé et
oui voilà avec ses
réserves alors madame Diaz je vais pas
répondre à quelque chose que je
considère comme un peu insultant mais
enfin je veux bien je sais pas
comment justifier mon bilan
dérisoire par rapport à tout l'argent
qu'on coûte à la République je sais pas
quoi vous dire moi je ne trouve pas
dérisoire parce que on fait avancer les
choses mine de rien dans les lieux qu'on
visite que ce soit en psychiatrie pour
vous ce sont de petites choses minables
certainement mais pour les gens qui sont
enfermés et pour les gens qui les
gardent ça n'est pas rien du
tout je sais pas quoi vous
dire je je crois avoir répondu sur la
surpopulation et et et déjà l'an dernier
sur notre énorme budget et bilan des
risir voilà sur la frontière italienne
oui c'est un gros problème c'estes lieux
d'enfermement j'en ai vu à la frontière
entre la France et l'Angleterre et
c'était des camions des containers
fermés bah voilà on propose leur
suppression pour que alors évidemment
c'est très compliqué parce que ce sont
des lieux où les gens sont enfermés un
nombre d'heures très restreints qui nous
permet pas toujours de sur eux ou alors
il faudrait qu'on reste là avec des
jumelles à observer qui rentre et qui
sort donc on s'en reparlera si vous
voulez puisque on m'a dit qu'il fallait
se dépêcher tu dire quelque chose juste
nous avions fait les mêmes constats et
demander que c'est que ce lieu soit
couvert par un cadre
juridique je reprends donc la nouvelle
série de questions Monsieur Emmanuel
Mandon
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la contrôleur générale je voudrais
souligner que votre rapport a mérite de
rappeler une situation très préoccupante
et j'y reviendrai pas car au-delà des
constats nous avons le devoir tous de
rechercher des solutions concrètes et
réalistes je voudrais donc vous
interroger sur le travail en prison ce
qui nous ramène à la question du sens de
la peine à celle de la réinsertion des
des détenus à la lutte contre le risque
beaucoup trop élevé de récidive selon
vos chiffres en France seulement 25 %
des détenus travail en Allemagne on
affiche un taux de 70 %. j'ai rencontré
avanttiier dans mon département le chef
Thierry Marx dont on se souvient qu'il
avait proposé d'introduire il y a 20 ans
des cours de cuisine en prison avec la
possibilité d'obtenir un bac pro et son
expérience lui lui faisait dire que le
taux de récidive baisse
significativement dès lors qu'il y a un
projet professionnel pour les détenus on
se souvient que la loi de de juin
1987 depuis cette loi le travail des
détenus n'est plus obligatoire en France
et depuis cette date et l'ordonnance du
1er mai 2022 la personne détenue qui
souhaite travailler doit demander à être
classé au travail par l'administration
pénitentiaire sur volontariat et son
recrutement se fait via un contrat
d'emploi pénitentiaire vous craignez que
le manque de travail proposé et la
faiblesse de l'offre de travail ne
compromettent la pleine effectivité de
ce nouveau régime alors que le Parlement
se penche actuellement sur la création
d'un contrat d'engagement de 15
he hebom d'activité obligatoire afin de
permettre le retour à l'emploi des
personnes qui en sont le plus
éloigné ne pensez-vous pas que pour les
détenus de fait éloigné de l'emploi
c'est certain le rétablissement en
prison de l'obligation de travail et ou
d'un projet
professionnel permettrait de structurer
une véritable offre de travail avec la
signature de partenariat d'entreprise et
de créer ainsi de réelles conditions de
réinsertion merci Mad
mar
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la contrôleure générale chers collègues
je souhaiterais revenir sur le volet
numéro 3 de votre rapport thématique
intitulé l'intimité au risque de la
privation de liberté vous y évoquez
notamment ce que vous jugez comme une
entrave des prisonniers dans leur
relation avec l'extérieur vous déplorez
que les prisonniers ne bénéficient pas
de confidentialité dans leur
communication téléphonique et que je
cite les points fon soit installé dans
les espaces communs qu'il y ait la
présence de professionnels pendant les
appels et une suroccupation et
occupation collective des cellules vous
indiquez aussi dans tous les lieux
visités de tenir un téléphone portable
généralement interdit ou s'accompagne de
restrictions partielles en mai dernier
un détenu de la prison de grâce a été
condamné pour avoir dirigé grâce à une
flotte de téléphone et depuis sa cellule
un important trafic de stupéfiant dans
la cité de la caayole à Marseille de
rond à camp en passant par Nessi ou
châteurou des détenus des établissements
pénitentiaires de céville ont été
surpris en train de menacer de mort leur
ancienne compagne par téléphone comment
entendez-vous donc concilier le respect
de intimité des détenus et notamment le
respect de leur conversation
téléphonique avec la sécurité publique
de la même manière vous déplorez qu'il
existe je cite un moyen de contrainte
comme le port de menotte ou à forcerie
d'entrave qui entraîne un rapport de
soumission inhérant à la domination
physique vous dites également c'est de
cas lors de l'arrivée dans certains
lieux de privation de liberté ou du fait
de l'organisation des locaux les
personnes privées de liberté menotées ou
accompagner d'une escorte doivent
circuler sous le regard du public
comment madame le contrôleur général
entendez-vous permettre au personnel des
établissements pénitentiaires de
préserver l'ordre de leur prison sans
usage de contrainte légitime à l'égard
de personnes qui ont été condamnées par
le système judiciaire français je vous
remercie monsieur
rirberot
présadameôleur simplement deux questions
d'abord j'ai été
attiré dans la par la page 16 de votre
rapport sur ce que vous dites sur les
mesures qui ont été prises au moment du
covid
en matière d'allègement de la population
carcérale bon d'abord parce que vous
soullignez quelque chose de positif ce
qui est assez rare et ensuite parce
que vous vous en vous n'en tirez pas de
conclusion en quelque sorte j'aimerais
savoir ce que vous tirez comme
conclusion de ce rapport assez positif
que vous rendez sur cette mesure et
deuxième
élément comment vous expliquer qu'on a
vraiment du mal en France à mettre en
place à mobiliser les moyens alternatifs
à la prison parce que ça ressort dans
votre rapport on sent bien qu'il y a une
panel un panel de propositions mais
qu'on a du mal en réalité à sortir entre
guillemets du tout
prison Monsieur
andbrat Merci monsieur le Président
Madame Simono madame la contrôleur
générale des lieu de privation liberté
vous en avez parlé vous-même he vous
vous avez parlé de l'abandon de l'État
et l'abandon de l'État il se retrouve
aussi dans les centres de rétention
administrative envers les retenus et les
agents on a tous entendu pour ceux qui
visitent les centres de rétention
administrative pour ma part j'en ai
visité se et je continuerai en vue de la
loi asile immigration mais bien sûr
après et quand on a pas une vision
partisane et qu'on essaie de vouloir
améliorer les situations on a tous
entendu cette phrase c'est pire que la
prison je préférerais être envoyé au BL
tout de suite tout le monde le dit et
moi il y a une alerte et je ce n'est pas
par rapport à votre rapport forcément
que je voulais vous poser une question
mais plus par rapport aux
recommandations d'urgence que vous avez
pu faire euh cet été euh euh suite à
différents événements euh et moi je vais
parler de quelques événements qui sont
par exemple le la mort de d'un retenu le
26 mai au CRAT Vincen un autre euh en le
3 juillet au CRAT au CR CRAT Vincen et
là c'est au Crâ Marseille euh au nombre
de tentatives de suicide qui ont
augmenté depuis la crise covid aux
agents qui ont mis fin à leur jour et je
pense à celui de Rennes en 2020 qui
s'est suicidé au sein du cras de Rennes
et vous avez
vous-même constaté les conditions
d'enfermement qui sont gravement
attentatoir à la dignité au droits
fondamentaux des personnes et on l'a
tous vu hein des locaux d'hébergement
vetust des conditions d'hygiène
déplorable peu de respect de la dignité
humaine l'intimité pas de pas de des
roues aux toilettes des portes défoncées
à Vincen
particulièrement je vais donc vous poser
une simple question madame la contrôleur
général c'est après tel constat jvous
que c'est bon que c'est aller dans le
bon sens que de pouvoir ouvrir de
nouvelles places de centes de rétention
administrative et d'augmenter le nombre
de qtf et j'en profite juste très
rapidement de votre présence pour
alerter de nouveau monsieur le
présidentoulier à qui j'avais adressé un
courrier par par écrit pour une demande
de création d'une mission flash sur la
le sujet de la rétention la République
ne peut pas pas fermer les yeux sur ces
lieux dans lequel elle enferme et
malmène des ressortissants étrangers
sans quoi elle contrevient à ses
principes universels merci je vous
rappelle simplement monsieur kerbra que
cette décision é soumise à
l'appréciation du bureau et que nous
avons examiné une loi de programmation
mère l'intérieur sur lequel nous avons
traité la rétention une loi immigration
qui arrive arriverait devant le
parlementuiser que le conditionnel à cet
égard et qu'une mission d'information
être conduite sur la régulation
carcérale et les alternatives à la
détention attention monsieur madame
cécilemeillur merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président merci
arriver merci beaucoup
euh madame la Présidente le constat il
est terrible euh c'est vrai que année
après année vous venez devant nous
dénoncer une situation que nous
connaissons et vous voyons bien que nous
n'avons pas trouvé les portes de sortie
je voulais vous poser une question sur
un sujet qui va revenir à à l'Assemblée
nationale qui n'est pas dans votre
rapport mais qui est sur le site et qui
concerne euh les tests
osux auquels il est fréquemment recouru
pour déterminer l'âge d'une personne et
donc vous appuyez sans réserve les
recommandations du Comité des droits de
l'enfant tendant à l'abandon d'un examen
dont la fiabilité est largement et
depuis longtemps contestée par les
scientifiques je vous cite et j'aurais
souhaité savoir si vous mainteniez à à
l'AUE de examen d'un projet d'un projet
de loi d'une proposition de loi vous
confirmez toujours cette
analyse et nous dire le cas échéant les
effets déléires qu'elle aurait pu
provoquer ma deuxième question c'est
d'abord un remerciement de nous alertter
sur le statut de l'enfant je pense que
nous sommes en de ça par rapport aux
préconisation de la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
nous sommes 1ès an de ça tant dans la
société que dans la prison qui en est le
reflet et je voulais euh à cette
occasion vous demander notre votre
soutien pour que les enfants de laazu
puissent bénéficier euh de la présence
d'un avocat qui euh soit au droit de
l'enfant alors même que celui-ci a été
abandonné très souvent il est seul et ce
n'est pas dans un une une confrontation
uniquement avec le juge que la solution
la plus adaptée doit être vérifiée il y
a un suivi il y a une une importance
majeure me semble-t-il à ce que euh
l'avocat soit présent auprès de l'enfant
abandonné fragilisé et la Convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
nous le commande et ma dernière question
c'est sur l'attractivité des personnels
moi j'ai très peur qu'on ait plus
personne qui veuille travailler à la
fois et dans les présons en dehors des
prisons monsieur Stéphane
[Musique]
rambau merci monsieur le Président
Madame la contrôleur générale des lieux
de privation de
liberté la surpopulation carcérale en
France vous le savez atteint des niveaux
alarmants selon les chiffres publiés par
le ministère de la Justice en août
dernier la France compte 74000 détenu
pour un peu plus de 60000 places
disponibles la densité carcérale
s'établit à 122 % cont contre 118 il y a
1 an ces chiffres prennent une résonance
particulière lorsque l'on prend en
compte le fait que près de 25 % des D
tenus sont étrangers représentant un
coût annuel de 700 millions d'euros dans
ce contexte il est d'autant plus
pertinent de rappeler qu'une enquête de
l'institut CSA de juillet 2022 montre
que 72 % des Français souhaitent que les
étrangers condamnés sur notre sol
exécutent leur peine dans leur pays
d'origine face à ces éléments ma
question est la suivante allez-vous
encourager le gouvernement à se saisir
activement de cette problématique et à
entamer des négociations diplomatiques
avec les pays concernés pour que les
étrangers condamnés exécutent leur peine
dans leur pays d'origine cela pourrait
être une réponse temporaire à
l'engorgement de nos prisons en
attendant la réalisation des promesses
du Président Emmanuel Macron concernant
la création des nouvelles places de plus
face à la perspective d'une détention
dans des conditions souvent plus rudes à
l'étranger cette mesure pourrait
également servir de dissuasion à la
Commission de CRIM et délits sur le
territoire
français Madame and tours
bien merci monsieur le Président Madame
la contrôleur générale des lieux de
privation de liberté d'abord moi je
tiens à vous remercier ci grandement
pour votre travail précieux pour la
défense des droits fondamentaux la
défense des valeurs humaines dont le
rassemblement national semble avoir une
vision restreinte ou à géométrie
variable si jamais il en a une la
question du du fonctionnement de la
psychiatrie et des traitements qu'elle
emploie révèle la vision de notre
société à l'égard des malades mentaux
plus de 8 ans après la création des
asiles Albert Londres considérait que
celle-ci n'était pasond F sur la volonté
de soigner mais relever plutôt de la
volonté de mettre à l'écart et d'isoler
des personnes qui inspirent la crainte à
la société aujourd'hui si nous sommes
loin des modèles des asiles persistent
de gros problèmes en terme de droit par
rapport à la contention et à l'isolement
même si ces pratiques sont depuis peu
considérées officiellement comme une
privation de liberté et soumise donc au
contrôle
juridictionnel votre rapport soulligne
de nombreux dysfonctionnements basés
parfois sur un lexique pervers je vous
cite he volontairement ambigu que vous
relevez dans votre rapport euh isolement
thérapeutique ou prescrire un isolement
qui donne donc un caractère
médical certains soignants considèr
qu'il faut mettre un terme à ces
pratiques comme c'est déjà le cas dans
certains pays que pensez-vous de cette
proposition quel le piste pouvez-vous
donner au législateur pour faire
respecter les droits des patients dans
ces unités puisque vous constatez une
absence d'effectivité du contrôle
juridictionnel et enfin dernière
question concernant les enfants que
préconisez-vous concernant les patients
mineurs hospitalisés dont votre rapport
soulligne l'ambigué ou voire l'absence
de de statut puisque isolé en soins
libre alors que leur consentement n'a
pas été demandé mais a été donné par
leurs parents je vous remercie et enfin
Monsieur Philippe
Schrek
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
la contrôleur général votre rapport et
l'avis que vous avez publié le 25
juillet 2023 me semble-t-il repose sur
des postulats voir des références qui ne
sont pas exacte pour faire écho à une
question qui a été posée vous affirmez
que la vague de libération pendant la
période covid et de confinement s'est
accompagnée d'une baisse de la
délinquence je vous renvoie et au
chiffre du ministère de l'intérieur
c'est pas les notes c'est ceux du
ministère où l'on constate en 2020
nombre de d'homicide plus 55 victimes
violence volontaire plus 12 % violence
intrafiliale plus 14 %, viol plus 32 %
agression sexuelle autre que le viol
plus 31 % les seules violences qui n'ont
pas pendant cette période augmenté sont
celles routières puisque nous n'avions
pas le droit de rouler 2ème postulat
vous évoquez vous êtes dans votre rôle
la détresse des détenus euh et
marginalement celle du personnel même si
ce n'est pas dans le périmètre de votre
mission est-ce que vous êtes déjà
confronté à la détresse d'une victime
est-ce que ça pourrait également
modifier l'éclairage enfin vous remettez
en cause le plan désormais 18000 places
prison euh deux questions à ce propos
euh d'une part la réalisation de ce plan
qui bien entendu est difficile mais
c'est pas parce qu'une chose est
difficile qu'elle doit être abandonnée
la réalisation de ce plan ne pas
participet-elle pas mécaniquement à la
diminution de la pression et de la
surpopulation carcérale c'est me
semble-t-il le sens de la réponse que
vous a adressé le garde des saau enfin
deuxièmement ce plan ne permet-il pas de
tendre vers l'amélioration de la dignité
des conditions de détention par le
renouvellement de cellules totalement
désuettes indigne et obsolète et puisque
vous visitez les prisons de ville s
finissant parnante après Gradignan
Perpignan je vous invite à venir à
Draguignan où il s'agit d'une prison
récente et peut-être pourriez-vous
apprécier le progrès dans la dignité que
ces nouvelles prisons peuvent apporter
au détenus je vous remercie simplement à
vous donner la parole madame la contr
contrôleur générale pour que soit clair
pour tout le monde pour le plan 15000
places de prison 15000 places sont
prévues dans la programmation budgétaire
au titre de l'article 1er de la loi de
programmation du ministère de la Justice
3000 sont envisagés dans le rapport
annexé assujetti à aucun financement et
conditionné à la réalisation préalable
et à la délivrance des autorisations
d'urbanisme par les collectivités
locales de la réalisation des 15000
premières places voilà la réalité de ce
que nous avons voté définitivement en
première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale
vrai
alors Monsieur Landon parler des
recherches et sur de rendre obligatoire
le travail en prison mais la loi le veut
déjà le détenu
doit
obligatoirement
pardon oui mais la loi le oui ben je le
comprends je le déplore aussi parce que
la loi prévoit que le détenu doit
répondre positivement aux propositions
qui lui sont faites et malheureusement
ces propositions n'arrivent pas moi si
vous voulez que on en reparle plus tard
moi je serai ravis que on on puisse
échanger sur le travail en prison mais
on a eu des prestataires notamment qui
nous disait ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure la difficulté d'entrer en prison
rebute beaucoup euh
ensuite il y a la frilosité des des con
des des employeurs qui sont parfois des
marques de grand luxe qui confient au
détenu on m'a dit surtout ne ne racontez
pas quelle
marque avec quelle marque les travaill
les détenus parce que euh mais mes
commanditaires ne veulent surtout pas
que que le les dames qui achètent leur
rouge à lèvres apprennent que ils sont
mis en en ils sont conditionnés par des
grosses paluches de détenus bon il y a
eu un moment aussi où un concessionnaire
est venu enfin un commanditaire est venu
à l'atelier voir il se trouvait qu'il
est venu à l'improviste et que c'était
jonché de crottes de rat la suite de
quoi je crois qu'il a retiré ses crèmes
de l'atelier
travail
donc pour tout ça pour vous dire qu'il y
a de il y a de nombreux il y a de
nombreuses entraves au fait on devrait
le rendre plus simple c'est comme je
disais tout à l'heure ce prof qui a fini
par renoncer parce qu'il lu fallait 2
heures chaque fois pour rentrer dans la
prison il y a beaucoup de on devrait
lever pas mal
d'entraves sur la possibilité de travail
des détenus peut-être ça faciliterait
les choses et encore une fois prendre
exemple sur l'Allemagne
où je me suis rendu pour voir c'était
c'était vraiment parlant
ensuite alors madame laureo sur sur le
portable en prison moi je je ce qu'on
dit dans notre rapport intimité c'est
que c'est vrai c'est gênant quand on est
dans une cellule enfermé à trois ou
quatre de devoir
parler à sa famille devant tout le monde
à ses proches alors j'imagine oui c'est
encore plus gênant quand on dirige un
trafic de stup mais alors là c'est pas
depuis la cellule c'est depuis des
portables comme vous le savez les
portables sont interdits en détention on
ferait peut-être mieux de les
autoriser sous
surveillance je sais pas si je vous ai
raconté cette histoire un jour de grande
fouille des cellules les les
surveillants ramassent tous les
portables et dans la journée ils ont
deux coup de fil de deux juges
d'instruction qui disent malheureux
rendez-leur leur portable immédiatement
ils sont sur écoute dans le cadre de
l'instruction que je dirige et on a été
obligé de leur rendre leur portable donc
c'est possible d'écouter les portables
qui sont en prison c'est c'est borné
comme partout et c'est bornés et comme
sont écoutés d'ailleurs la possibilité
d'écouter les détenus qui appellent de
leur cellules donc la solution est
peut-être celle-là il y a une grande
hypocrisie à interdire les porta en
prison alors qu'on sait que qu'ils en
ont tous et qu'en plus ça crée du
Kaïa avec ceux qui sont obligés de les
ramasser quand ils tombent dans la cour
de promenade c'est un nouveau métier qui
est né ramasseur il y a lanceur
ramasseur et il y a nourrice comme on
dit c'estàdire ceux qui sont obligés de
les garder en cellule sous la menace des
autres c'est un énorme problème j'en
conviens et je me demande s'il faudrait
pas mieux le réglementer plutôt que de
l'interdire tout court vous avez comme
l'esprit humain est intelligent et qui
et qui se balade entre les interdictions
de façon à les contourner toujours
je je sais pas quoi vous dire de plus
que ça sur ce qui est des menotes oui
nous déplorons parce que on voit que
pour certains détenus elles sont
appliqué le le menotage et les escorte
vous savez de niveau 1 2 ou
3 sont pas tellement dirig sont pas
tellement décidé en fonction de la
dangerosité mais en fonction d'un
sentiment
elles sont quand même extrêmement
généralisées et ça aboué au fait que les
détenus certains détenus arrivent à
l'hôpital accompagné de trois
surveillants beauté masqué et que et que
ça donne des consultations pas tellement
dans des très bonnes conditions ça M Mme
même certains médecins all les refuser
voyez et puis il y a surtout un problème
d'extraction médicale énorme qui voit
que il y a comme il y a pas l'escorte et
ben il y a pas de soins il y a pas
d'extraction vers
l'hôpital alors euh je te sais un peu
injuste monsieur rberot le le le
reproche de quelle le Sonon tiré du
covid au contraire on en a attirré
beaucoup parce que nous on appelait à ce
que se reproduise
cette c'est cette façon de réguler la la
population carcérale vous savez
peut-être c'est inspiré de mes premières
années qui sont de vie professionnelle
mes 10 premières années quand même qui
sont pas du tout naïve et qui sont pas
du
tout et qui font que je je ne peux que
penser au personnel pénitentiaire
puisque j'ai été moi-même 10 ans
éducatrice à la pénitentiaire
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui on dit s pipes
euh donc je connais bien c'est un milieu
que je connais bien c'est un milieu que
j'ai continué à fréquenter où j'ai gardé
des amis et où on continue à échanger
donc je trouve ça enfin bon j'ai des
liens avec ce milieu et je continuerai à
en avoir
et je trouve le reproche fait un
peu je parle pas de votre question
monsieur rberot euh et je ne comprends
pas pourquoi on a tellement de mal en
France à sortir du tout prison je vous
avoue moi aussi je suis étonnée ça fait
des années que on en parle des années
que la solution paraît moi je me
souviens quand j'étais éduque à la
pénitentiare comme on disait tous les 14
juillet on attendait de pieds fermes les
5000 sorties du au décret de grâce
collective qui ont été supprimé
peut-être ce serait la solution la plus
simple serait de la
rétablir puisque on n'arrive pas à
s'entendre sur sur un un projet un
mécanisme de régulation carcérale nous
on attendait on avait notre caisse de
secours ça s'est beaucoup amélioré dein
les sorties sont beaucoup
amélioré mais il y a plus cette loi on
on avait notre Cisse secours notre liste
de foyer notre liste d'hôtel notre liste
de
boulot bon ben en tout cas le résultat
est là là les prisons sont invivables tu
veux me montrer quelque chose ah
bon je me dépêche
euh moi je suis je seraai toujours
d'accord pour pronner qu'on sorte du
tout prison je il y a d'autres pays où
on applique le moins de prison il y a
pas plus de
délinquence
qu'ici il y a même ici plus de récidif
qu'ailleurs parce que les sorti de
prison euh quand on a rien appris que et
qu'on a rien fait de tout ce temps
passer de ce temps mort et ben on sort
dans un état euh pas meilleur qu'on est
entré et je rappelle que la loi veut que
la prison propose de la réinsertion des
activités du travail et cetera et et que
là elle n'est incapable en maison
d'arrêt de de de proposer quoi que ce
soit que que des choses de
contraintte
malheureusement c'est extrêmement
regrettable alors dans les centres de de
rétention bah vous avez lu nos
recommandations euh euh et les nouvelles
alors que le nombre c'est c'est
d'ailleurs le nombre d'qtf est très mal
connu parce qu'il est euh très peu rendu
publ euh évidemment pas parce que comme
ça on fait le rapport entre le taux
d'exécution et et qui est bah sous 10 %
euh donc si on est une machine à
fabriquer des octtf forcément le taux
d'exécution des octtf baisse
euh et construire de nouvelles places de
cras moi j'ai quand même eu la surprise
pour vous dire à quel point c'est les
agents ne rentrent pas en zone de vie de
trouver à Lyon des des graffitis en caca
sur les murs don trois croix gamé
et qui étaient là depuis longtemps dans
une odeur pestilentielle et qui qui
n'avait pas été nettoyé ou qui n'avait
choqué
personne et le centre de rétention de
Lyon le nouveau qui doit servir
d'exemple aux autres et ben c'est sur
lui c'est à partir de ça qu'on a fait
des recommandations en urgence pour dire
c'est impossible de retenir des gens
dans ces conditions 3 mois pour qu'ils
ne partent
pas alors madame
ur sur la fiabilité des testosux euh bah
oui c'est l'Académie de médecine Qui a
dit même qu'ils étaient pas qu'ils
étaient pas fiables donc oui je je
constate qu'on continue à s'y référer
avec affliction et quant à la présence
d'un avocat auprès des enfants de la je
crois pas que ce soit mon rôle enfin je
suis tout à fait prête quand même à
l'appuyer parce que c'est
absolument normal je
crois alors Monsieur Romba c'est ça la
surpopulation est alarmante la densité
certes n'est même pas de elle est de 122
% globalement mais c'est un leur parce
qu'elle est d'environ 150 % dans les
maisons
d'arrêt où on exécute les courtes peine
où les gens sont en attente de transfert
et où sont les présumés innocents alors
vous me dites 7 122 % des Français
souhaitent que les détenus étrangers
exécutent leur peine dans leur pays
d'origine moi je vous répondrai que je
suis pas là pour commenter des sondages
ni répondre à des sondages ni obéir à
des sondages euh mais c'est un fait que
euh
euh c'est c'est je pense que le
gouvernement euh n'est pas plus euh bête
que vous ou moi et qui ils essayent tout
pour que ces détenus repartent dans leur
pays d'origine euh et que et que les
retenus partent dans leur pays d'origine
et que simplement les pays d'origine
sont pas plus bêtes que personne
pourquoi voulez-vous qu'ils reprennent
des gens qui sortent de prison euh qui
qui ont vocation à être chômeur et qui
vont venir les embêter dans leur pays
donc ils répondent ammanquablement c'est
pas à nous en ce moment il y a plus un
Algérien plus un Marocain qui repart et
les efforts diplomatiques je suis sûr
qu'ils sont faits y compris en payant
mais pour le moment vous voyez qu'ils
aboutissent très peu et je doute même
que d'autres efforts venant d'autres
d'autres parties aboutissent c'est
simplement une question de réalité vous
savez les Maliens je doute qu'il
repartent également et à un moment les
Maliens
le le président malien nous avait dit
c'était il y a longtemps avait déclaré à
la France moi aussi j'ai un peuple et
moi aussi me juge face à ce que je fais
par rapport à mon peuple à la
diaspora je sais pas quoi vous dire vous
vous verrez si vous arrivez au pouvoir
que vous ne ferez pas mieux je pense pas
je je je ne crois
pas oui on sait jamais on sait
jamais
et madameé je vais laisser André vous
répondre sur la psychiatrie il est plus
balaise que moi
oui il y a TR question le premier c'est
que vous faites écho à ce que nous avons
dit sur la perversité du langage
effectivement les professionnels ont
souvent une vraie difficulté à admettre
la réalité et la dureté de leur exercice
professionnel et la tentation de masquer
cet exercice professionnel derrière des
mots plus acceptables que les choses est
grande alors on a comme
ça le mot prescription qui remplace le
mot décision ce qui revient à faire très
bon marché du fait que dans une
prescription l'élément moteur de du du
système c'est la consentement du patient
qui n'est pas le cas quand on exécute
soi-même une décision qu'on prend on a
cette question qui nous est
particulièrement pénible au CGLPL j'en
ai déjà parlé celle de de la notion de
soins intensifs qui consiste à désigner
des espèces de C de Bass faus dans
lesquels on on entrepose des patients
parce qu'on n' pas assez de monde pour
les soigner et donc non seulement il n'y
a pas de d'intensité mais il n'y a pas
toujours non plus de de soins et donc ça
malheureusement c'est quelque chose
contre quoi nous luttons mais qui est un
réflexe de protection euh spontanée je
pense du du du personnel des
établissements de santé mental eu
évidemment un réflexe de protextion que
l'on peut comprendre puisqu'il s'agit de
se défendre leur propre image euh sur
euh la la question de l'entrée en
vigueur des des des protections
juridiques et les difficultés qui en euh
qui euh en découle euh je je crois que
j'ai pas évidemment de de solution
miracle si ce n'est celle qu'il faut
laisser du temps au temps parce que le
monde judiciaire et le monde médical
apprennent à se connaître et ne peuvent
pas évidemment le faire très rapidement
en revanche il y a une il est dans une
mesure récente qui est le droit de
visite des bâtonniers dans les lieux de
privation de liberté je soulligne la
lacune que constitue l'absence de droit
de visite des bâtonniers dans les établ
issement de santé mentale certains s'y
sont présentés récemment et ont été
accueillis parce que les établissements
de santé mentale sont plutôt ouverts
néanmoins ils n'ont pas cette
prérogative dans la loi et je pense que
je pense que c'est une lacune réelle euh
voilà la première la première piste
législative à laquelle je pense les
autres pistes législatives c'est de
combler les lacune c'est-à-dire de de
juridictionnaliser le contrôle du
placement en UMD du placement en musip
euh et de
euh juridictionnaliser enfin il y a une
une décision du récente du tribunal des
conflit qui je pense vous conduira à
réglementer à légiférer sur ce sur ce
point qui fait entrer un pas de plus le
juge judiciaire dans le dans dans le
champ de de de la protection de la
liberté au regard des établissements de
santé mentale euh j'appelle votre
attention aussi sur le fait qu'il y a
deux décrets récent euh du euh de de sur
l'organisation des services de
psychiatrie et sur les autorisations en
psychiatrie qui vont très probablement
ouvrir bientôt un champ à la
jurisprudence administrative puisque euh
il n'y avait pas de cadre il y en a
désormais un la question de la
conformité à ce cadre va donc pouvoir
être traduite devant le juge et et et
donc ça c'est ça c'est un progrès euh
dans dans le contrôle de de la de la
psychiatrie enfin votre dernière
question portéit sur les patients
mineurs euh il y a ce que nous
soulignons dans le rapport cette
ambiguité très grave autour du fait que
les patients mineurs sont fictivement
déclarés en soins libre alors qu'ils
sont enfermé sur la base de la volonté
certes libre mais pas de la leur puisque
c'est celle de leur patient donc ce que
nous avons préconisé dans un rapport
déjà ancien sur l'accueil des mineurs en
psychiatrie c'est que tout enfant mineur
placé en établissement de santé mentale
bénéficie quel que soit son statut de
placement d'une protection équivalente
comparable transposer ce qu'on voudra en
respectant évidemment le monopole de de
juridiction du juge des
enfants mais équivalente à celle des
mineurs des majeurs en soins sans
consentement puisque un mineur placé sur
la libre volonté de ses parents ne peut
pas être regardé au moins par nous comme
en soin libre il doit donc avoir une
protection juridictionnelle équivalente
mais plus largement que ça
euh ce qui nous paraît manquer beaucoup
c'est un statut du mineur hospitalisé
statut du mineur qui prend devrait
prendre en compte évidemment la question
de la de la protection de sa liberté
mais aussi la question de son accès à
l'enseignement la question des modalités
d'exercice de l'autorité parentale sur
sur cet enfant et la question globale de
l'ensemble des droits à l'information à
la protection de cet enfant je je je je
revient sur l'idée que disait madame
ununtermeyer si on
consent un un avocat systématique pour
assister les enfants placés à laaz il
n'y a pas de raison que ceux qui sont
placés en établissement de santé mentale
met une moindre
protection et ben je remercie pour cette
audition et pour la complétude de vos
réponses aux questions des
parlementaires moi je dois répondre à
Monsieur Shrek ah bah alors ser allez
attendez
allez-y quasi complétude alors répondez
à Monsieur Schrek pour pas qu'il soit
Marie
oui merci c'est ça que euh alors vous
vous m'avez demandé si j'avais déjà été
confronté à des victimes monsieur Shrek
oui bien sûr comme tout le monde vu
l'âge que j'ai en plus beaucoup de
victimes même et vu les métiers que j'ai
exercé et non ça ne change pas ma façon
de voir parce que je pense que si les
détenus sorte euh en meilleur état et
sans récidif sera meilleur pour tout le
monde et y compris pour les victimes
ensuite le plan 15000 bah je vous ai dit
ce que j'en pensais je
c'est 15000 j'ai fâché j'ai fâché votre
président en disant que je n'y crois pas
mais bon on verra bien euh plus pour me
fâcher fa fâcher faut y aller ils
essaient tous les jours ah bon B alors
ça va tout M et quant à à la prison de
Draguignan vous verrez nous en nous en
sortons et vous verrez bientôt le
rapport que nous allons élaborer et et
je vais vous surprendre peut-être mais
il vous fera sûrement
plaisir pour une fois hein
ou merci c cette fois les propos sont
complets et les réponses je vous
remercie bonne journée à toutes et tous